Ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch y
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch ychwanegwch.
Mae'n dda iawn i'r hyn o bryd.
Diolch i'r cymdeithasol cymdeithasol a'r Prif Weinidog i'w bod yn ystod yma.
Rwy'n dechrau i'n gweithio'n bwysig fy hun am ddweud ymlaen.
Mae'r cymdeithasol Cymru'n gweithio am gweithio gweithio gweithio gweithio cymdeithasol a chymdeithasol
Mae'r cymdeithasol cymdeithasol cymdeithasol cymdeithasol a chymdeithasol ymlaen.
Mae'r cymdeithasol Cymru'n gweithio am gweithio gweithio cymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithas
a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymde
a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol a chymdeithasol.
Mae hynny'n anodd i fy nghymdeithasol yn Cymru oherwydd mae'n helpu i gynllunio gweithredu gweithredu gweithredu gweithredu a gweithredu gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweith
a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu
a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithredu a gweithre
Rydw i'n gobeithio'n gweithredu'r cyfleoedd yma yn y cyfleoedd yma
ac yn y blynyddoedd hynny, rydw i'n edrych ar gyfer ymddygiad
sut gallwn ni gweithio gyda'r cyfleoedd i sicrhau bod y programe sy'n bwysig i'r Amgueddfeydd Amgueddfeydd
a'r cyfleoedd amgueddfeydd Amgueddfeydd a'r cyfleoedd amgueddfeydd
Rydw i'n edrych ar y cyfleoedd o'r cyfleoedd yma, Mr. Cartwright.
Thank you, Chairman Rogers, and I'd like to join you in welcoming Secretary Gina Raimondo back to our subcommittee.
Madam Secretary, as we all know, it's been an extremely busy two years at the Department of Commerce.
You've been engaging in your ordinary year-to-year responsibilities, everything from census surveys,
to export control enforcement, to forecasting severe weather.
The Department is now involved in the massive effort to bring semiconductor production back to the United States,
as provided for in the Chips and Science Act, approved by the last Congress and signed by President Biden.
The Department is also busy implementing funding to help expand high-speed internet access
and to support climate resilience efforts as provided in the IIJA and the Inflation Reduction Act,
also both approved by the last Congress.
In the middle of all of this, I was overjoyed to welcome you to my district in Northeastern Pennsylvania.
We had some very productive discussions, and Pittston's own mayor, Mike Lombardo, is one of your top fans at this point.
The President's Fiscal Year 2024 Budget is the subject of today's hearing.
You have a request of $12.1 billion for the Department of Commerce.
It represents an increase of $1.1 billion, or just over 10%,
for what are important and diverse missions of the Department of Commerce,
all of them critical for the quality of life of the American people and American competitiveness in the world.
Your department plays an important role to help strengthen and secure our supply chains,
which we became painfully aware of during the pandemic,
and you help keep American businesses successful in the global trade market.
I'm pleased that your request includes strong funding increases for the Economic Development Administration,
as well as the Manufacturing Extension Partnership Program, which we discussed in Pittston,
to help create jobs and economic opportunity and to strengthen our nation's manufacturing base.
Among many other initiatives, this request includes strong funding for investments in next-generation weather satellites
to help provide more accurate weather forecasting that American citizens and American businesses rely on,
as well as a strong funding increase for the Bureau of Industry and Security
to help expand its capacity for export enforcement, both domestically and overseas,
in order to prevent sensitive dual-use technologies from falling into the wrong hands.
I am, however, greatly concerned that proposals by many in Congress,
and there are voices out there talking about as much as 22% decreases in funding for departments across the board,
those calls for slashes in funding and discretionary spending will greatly damage the efforts that I just mentioned.
I look forward to discussing these issues at this hearing,
and I thank you, Madam Secretary, for joining us and providing us your testimony.
Mr. Chairman, I yield back.
Let me now recognize Ranking Member DeLauro for her opening statement.
Thank you very much, Mr. Chairman, to you, Chairman Rogers, and Ranking Member Cartwright.
Really, I'm happy to be here at this very critical hearing.
Thank you, Secretary Raimondo, for being here today.
When you took office two years ago, our nation was facing an economic crisis.
But with your leadership and the help of this committee,
we have made great strides to strengthen our supply chains to make our economy stronger and more competitive,
invest in economic development of our communities,
and to help the U.S. in its manufacturers and small businesses to be able to grow, to be able to thrive.
To build on this success, President Biden proposed a budget
that meets the needs of families and communities all across America.
I'm particularly pleased to see a proposed 56% increase for the Economic Development Administration, EDA.
Fostering equity and opportunity for Americans, regardless of zip code or background,
is one of the most important duties of this subcommittee.
And the funding proposed for EDA would make innovation more geographically and more racially diverse
and create good jobs for underserved and vulnerable communities that need them.
I'm also pleased that the budget proposes a 58% increase for the Manufacturing Extension Partnership Program,
which helps small and medium-sized U.S. manufacturers create and preserve jobs to help them thrive in the global economy.
To make our economy even more competitive, Congress met the moment.
And past the Chips and Science Act last year, let me say a thank you to you and to your staff
for all of the work that was done on this effort and all the work that you are doing,
including through the budget request to ensure that the impact of Chips and Science is actualized.
This is critical to strengthening our supply chain.
But to do so, we must also take action to safeguard our national security and supply chain resiliency.
I was pleased to see the International Trade Administration's budget proposes increased funding
to assist the Treasury Department in the establishment of an outbound investment review mechanism,
similar to proposals I outlined in my bipartisan National Critical Capabilities Defense Act.
This would ensure we can quickly address vulnerabilities and prevent offshoring of production capacity
and intellectual property to foreign adversaries.
Before I conclude, I must mention how worried I am that much of the progress I spoke about
can very well be at risk because of some of my Republican colleagues
and what they have called for, extreme cuts to government funding.
And yesterday on Wall Street, Speaker McCarthy reiterated his intent and others' intent to cut back funding
to a 2022 level and to lock in that austerity with caps for the next 10 years.
But make no mistake, caps are just another name for more cuts. Caps, in fact, are cuts.
As you mentioned in your letter to me on the impacts of these cuts, they would set our success back.
This kind of movement was reiterated by a very esteemed think tank,
the Heritage Foundation, which I know a number of my colleagues look into and look to for direction.
And what Heritage has suggested with regard to commerce is to eliminate the Commerce Department's
Economic Development Administration, eliminate the Commerce Department's Minority Business Development Agency,
eliminate Commerce's Hollings Manufacturing Extension Partnership,
and cut and cap funding for the National Science Foundation.
These cuts would endanger our national security by reducing our efforts to enforce export controls,
including those that keep goods and sensitive defense technologies away from our adversaries.
They would weaken our economic competitiveness by reducing our capacity to promote trade and investment
and, if implemented, the programs that create stronger communities
and better paying jobs across the nation would be dramatically reduced.
And initiatives to prepare for disasters and to adapt to a changing climate would be drastically cut.
The economic well-being of our communities cannot become victim to these efforts.
I, like you and this committee, will fight to continue strengthening our economy,
and we look forward to hearing from you, Secretary Raimondo, on the funding that you need to do so to keep our economy strong.
With that, let me just say a thank you to you, Chairman Rogers, and to Ranking Member Cartwright. I yield back.
Thank the Ranking Member.
We're pleased now to welcome to our subcommittee hearing Secretary Raimondo.
You're recognized for an opening statement.
Without objection, your written statement will be entered into the record.
I hope that you can keep your statement to five minutes or so, so we can have additional time for questions.
You're now recognized. Welcome.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Good afternoon, and thank you, Chairman Rogers, for presiding over this hearing.
Ranking Member Cartwright, it was wonderful to be with you in Pittston,
and thank you, Ranking Member DeLauro, for making the time to be here.
To members of the subcommittee, thank you for being here and thank you for giving me this opportunity to have a fulsome discussion,
and I hope to answer all of your questions with respect to President Biden's fiscal year 2024 budget request for the Department of Commerce.
Echoing much of what has been said, I would like to begin by saying that thanks to your hard work
and thanks to the major investments from the Bipartisan Infrastructure Law, the Bipartisan Chips and Science Act,
and your support throughout the appropriations process, the Commerce Department is hard at work
and operating on all cylinders to create jobs, improve economic conditions, and secure America's national security for all Americans.
Our goal is to make sure that America is well positioned to continue its leadership.
Everything we do with the Department of Commerce is designed to enhance America's ability to compete.
From the smallest companies to the biggest, we want to compete to allow America to lead in the world,
and I'm here today to ask you to build on those investments in fiscal year 2024 so that we can keep the momentum going,
continue to invest in American businesses, American communities, and American workers so that we can lead the world.
President Biden requests $12.3 billion in discretionary funding and $4 billion in mandatory funding for the Department.
In the interest of time and respectfully, Chairman, I'll just highlight a few of the requests.
My full written testimony obviously will go into the details,
but there is a focus in investing in manufacturing, innovation, and resilient supply chains.
It calls for $1.6 billion to support the work of NIST, including $277 million for the Manufacturing Extension Partnership, which has been referenced.
The funding will enable these MEP centers to expand coordination with the private sector,
to narrow the gaps in supply chains, and to enable especially small and medium-sized manufacturers
to adopt critical technologies which will help them be more resilient.
The budget provides for $98 million to expand NIST's role in Manufacturing USA,
including $60 million in new competitive awards to enable existing Manufacturing USA institutes
to promote domestic production of institute-developed technologies.
And it proposes $700 million for ITA, including $26 million to establish a Supply Chain Resiliency Office
to proactively identify and mitigate supply chain risks.
It also increases funding to SelectUSA to attract foreign domestic investment.
Fel wedi'i cymryd, ar gyfer mlynedd o amrygain, y pandemig oedd unrhyw beth yw'r cyfansoddiadau economaidd
sydd wedi'i ddechrau eu cyfansoddiadau, eu ffamiliau, a'u gweithredu eu gweithredu.
Yn ogystal â'r byd, mae gennym gysylltiadau sy'n gweithredu gyda gysylltiadau gweithredu a'u gweithredu i helpu y cyfansoddiadau.
Yn ogystal â hynny, mae'r budget yn gweithredu $4 miliwn yn gweithredu gynllun,
a $50 miliwn yn gysylltuadau dysgrifiaethol i'r EDA i gysylltu cymdeithasol, technoleg, a chyfansoddiadau gynllun,
i gysylltu gyfansoddiadau geograffig a chyfansoddiadau.
Mae'n cynnwys $200 miliwn i'r progrwm Pilot Recompeat i gynllunio grantau i'r cyfansoddiadau sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiadau sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiadau sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiad sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiad sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiad sy'n bwysig.
Mae'n cynnwys $100 miliwn i'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol, sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol a $100 miliwn i'r MBDA.
Felly rydw i'n cysylltu â'r hyn.
Yn y ffyrdd o ffyrdd, rydw i wedi gysylltu'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol sy'n bwysig i'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol o'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol o'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol o'r cyfansoddiadau cymdeithasol.
Mae'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r ffaith yw'r f
a ddod o'r cwestiwnau y gallwch chi gyd. Thank you.
Thank you, Madam Secretary.
We will now proceed under the five-minute rule for questions.
I'll begin by recognizing myself.
Madam Secretary, the Department of Commerce plays a critical role
in promoting economic growth and job creation.
From promoting trade and investment to protecting intellectual property
and supporting scientific research,
the department's work is essential to our nation's prosperity.
What key initiatives in the 24-budget request will have the greatest impact
on the department's overall mission of promoting economic growth and job creation?
In addition, how will the department ensure that these funds
are being used effectively and efficiently,
and what metrics or indicators will be used to measure the success of these investments?
Many of the increases proposed in your budget request
are for programs that received supplemental funding.
How will the 24 request build on the support that Congress has already provided?
Thank you for the question, Chairman Rogers.
Let me say I want to thank you—we've talked about this in the past—for your consistent support of EDA.
My short answer to your question is all of the programs,
but I want to focus specifically on a few in the EDA,
because I think they're particularly vital at this moment in time, given what our economy needs.
First of all, the tech hubs.
The omnibus included enough for a pilot in the tech hubs.
The budget asks for additional money in tech hubs.
There is innovation all across this country,
not just in Boston, Silicon Valley, and New York City,
and we need to invest in communities all around America to tap into that innovation.
We need to do that to create jobs in those communities,
but frankly we need to do that in order to compete in the world.
Success will mean communities all around the country
that have universities or companies that have leading-edge technology
or research and development in any area where we invest in them
so that they can flourish and create jobs in those communities.
I could include a new initiative called re-compete,
which I referenced in my opening statement,
which is a place-based economic development
focused on communities that are the most distressed.
Every one of you has some community in your state
that is chronically distressed and who都有 cael سwyth iawn.
We can't leave them behind.
I know in Kentucky you have these communities,
mae'r cyfansoddiadau hynny, ac felly mae hynny'n ymwneud â gweithredu economaidd ymlaen,
lle mae'n rhaid i ni helpu i'w gysylltu mewn beth maen nhw'n dda,
i weithredu pobl ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau heddiw a morfod,
ac yn y ffordd hynny, byddwn yn helpu America i ddod ymlaen,
i ddod eu cyfansoddiadau, a dydw i'n meddwl,
bod y cyfansoddiadau hynny'n bwysig ac equal.
Mae'r cyfansoddiadau hynny'n bwysig ac equal.
Mae'r cyfansoddiadau hynny'n bwysig ac ac equal.
Mae'r cyfansoddiadau hynny'n bwysig ac ac ac ac equal.
Mae'r cyfansoddiadau hynny'n cael eu cymryd.
Mae'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell Genedlaeth Cymru'n cymryd
bod y Deyrnas Unedig yn gallu ddechrau cyfrifiad cyfrifiad cyfrifiad
oherwydd y cysylltiad, y cyfrifiad a'r gysylltiadau.
Beth yw'r granns Beed sy'n ymwneud â'u cefnogi eu cefnogi?
Beth yw'r gweinidau cyfrifiad cyfrifiadol o'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell?
Beth yw'r gweinidau cyfrifiad cyfrifiad cyfrifiadol
a sut mae'r cyfrifiad yn gweithio i gysylltu'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell
Gweinidog Llyfrgell Gweinidog Llyfrgell
yn ymwneud â'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell Gweinidog Llyfrgell
yn ymwneud â'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell
Mae'r cyfrifiad cyfrifiad cyfrifiad cyfrifiad
Mae'r gweinidog Llyfrgell
yn ymwneud â'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell
Ymwneud â'r Gweinidog Llyfrgell
Mae'r ystod yn amlwg i ni
sut y byddant yn defnyddio moneg USDA,
sut y byddant yn defnyddio moneg FCC,
sut y byddant yn defnyddio ein moneg.
Felly mae'n amlwg i ni
gysylltu'r hyn yn ystod ystod
fel bod yn y ffordd o'r ddau
byddwn yn gweithio'n ddiddordeb
gyda'r unrhyw ddau
ac yn gwneud yn ymwneud â'r misiynau
i bawb sy'n cael brodband.
Nid yw'r hyn yn ymwneud â'r hyn
yn ymwneud â'r hyn
ymwneud â'r hyn
yn ymwneud â hyn
yn ymwneud â'r hyn
ymwneud â'r hyn
Ymwneud â'r hyn
yn ymwneud â'r hyn
ymwneud â'r hyn
Rwy'n glir bod y gweithwyr ymddiriedig wedi'i ddweud o'r Aelodau Aelodau, oherwydd bod y Prif Weinidog o'r Aelodau Aelodau Aelodau wedi'i ddweud y bydd y cysylltiadau'r amgylcheddau'r CCP'r amgylcheddau'n dweud nad oes biliadau o ddollars i helpu cymdeithas ymgylchedd cymdeithas, gyda'r amgylcheddau y byddai'r ddollars nid yw'r amgylcheddau'r cymdeithas o'r cymdeithas o'r cymdeithas yng Nghymru.
Felly, roeddwn i'n ddweud i chi, y text y Llywodraethau o'r Chips Act yn dweud y bydd cymdeithas ymgylcheddau'r amgylcheddau yn cael y pwynt o'r amgylcheddau o'r amgylcheddau yn cymdeithas gyda'r amgylcheddau cymdeithasol a'r amgylcheddau cymdeithasol cymdeithasol a'i gynnwys cymdeithas ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylchedd
ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol ymgylcheddau cymdeithasol
o saf ai os ydych wedi rhoi bai ddod eich bod yn ymwybod.
C slightly chi'n fawd i fesial y cymdeithasol.
o gynnyddio'r cyfansoddiadau y 2022 i'r cyfansoddiad y 2024.
Ac roeddwn i'n siŵr am EDA a sut y byddwn i'n fwyaf y byddai'r Prif Weinidog
wedi cael gwybodaeth yng Nghymru.
Ond mae'r Prif Weinidog wedi'u cymryd at y cwestiwn
am beth y byddai'r cyfansoddiadau o'r 2022 yn ymwneud â'r cyfansoddiad $155 miliwn
ar gyfer gynnydd o'r EDA.
Beth yw'r amser ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau os yw hynny'n digwydd?
A beth ymwneud â'r amser ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau?
Felly rydw i'n cael ei ddweud, mae'r EDA yn rhywbeth y byddwn i'n meddwl.
Mae'n dda gyda'r MBDA, oherwydd rydw i wedi'i gweld ymlaen.
Beth yw'r amser ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau.
Mae'r rhai o'r amser ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau.
Mae'r amser ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadu ar gyfer cyfansoddiad
ar gyfer cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiadau sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu cyfansoddiad sy'n cael eu
cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddi
cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n
cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad syfansoddiad syfansoddiad syfansoddiad syfansoddiad syfansoddiad sy'n
cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad sy'n cyfansoddiad syutter .
ыйn bi.
ac rwy'n gwybod eich bod chi'n gwybod hynny.
Mae'r Amgueddfeydd Amgueddfeydd Cymdeithasol Cymdeithasol.
Ond beth y bydd y pwyntiaeth ymgyrch ymgyrch
ar y gysylltiadau ymwneud â'r sefteriau add,
os ydych chi'n gwybod, oherwydd y pwyntiaeth sy'n cael eu cymryd
ar y gysylltiadau?
A bydd y Cymru'n edrych ar y gysylltiadau ymgyrch,
y gysylltiadau'n bwysig, y gysylltiadau'n bwysig,
oherwydd y pwyntiaeth sy'n cael eu cymryd
ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch ymgyrch y
Gwnaethom i gydnabydd yr annibodau a phosib wellordiol i wethu a phethau sy'n wynebu'n effaith ag y하고ld lawsg trinムgaeth Mobile.
одной sy'n dda – rwy'n bwysig am grain o fewn sy'n gadael â'n allai trin cheating, er mwyswyd i ei ddarparu pan fato mewn POC a gall줄 cyffrediniaeth 910 o prescription oGOC!
Byddwn yn dweud, y byddwn yn edrych ar yr hyn rydych chi'n dweud,
gyda'r lles ar gyfer ffocws cyngorol.
Rydyn ni'n gweithio gyda'r cymdeithasol cymdeithasol,
fel y gallwn,
i gynnwys cymdeithasol,
transparant, clyr i'r byd.
Mae'r byd yn bwysig i'r byd gwybodaeth
gwybodaeth i'w gwybod gyda'r hyn
y byd maen nhw'n gallu ymwneud yn.
Rydyn ni'n gweithio ar gyfer ffocws cyngorol,
ond rydyn ni'n gweithio ar gyfer ffocws cyngorol,
Rydyn ni'n credu y byddwn ni'n rhaid i'w wneud yw
ddechrau'r amser hwn
a gweithio i ddechrau'r amser
fel rydyn ni'n gallu
i ddechrau'r amser
i ddechrau'r amser ffocws cyngorol
trwy'r amserau eraill.
Mae'r amserau sy'n cael eu cymryd yn fawr.
Mae'r amser sy'n cael eu cymryd yn fawr.
Rydw i'n cymryd y Chips Act,
ond ar ôl 5 a 7 oriau yn y Skif
yn siarad yn y ffordd ymlaen o'r sefydliad hwnnw
ymlaen o'r sefydliad hwnnw
Rwy'n mynd i ddweud, ac mae'r ysgol yn gallu'i ddeall,
ond os gallwn ni gyrraedd ymlaen
yn y tanc, neu'r ymgysylltiadau ymlaen
gyda'r ymgysylltiadau,
sut rydyn ni'n mynd i'r ymgysylltuad
o'r ymgysylltuad yng Nghymru
a'r DOD i sicrhau bod ni'n
ymgysylltuad ymlaen
7-nanometer wafer
sy'n, ymgysylltuad, nid oes
amgylchedd yn unrhyw amgylchedd
yn unrhyw amgylchedd hypersonig neu amgylchedd DOD
Mae'r amgylchedd yn unrhyw amgylchedd
yn unrhyw amgylchedd
Why aren't we updating the entity list
and denied person lists
and putting more pressure on China
like we would do with, say, Iran
with a maximum pressure mindset?
Can you give me your perspective
either your personal perspective
where can we get better?
China is eating our lunch
literally and figuratively
and we feel like we're passive
You said the BIS needs to be
as aggressive as possible
but we're not actually being as aggressive as possible right now
so I'd just like to get your perspective on that
Can I answer?
Look, let me say this
If you have ideas
about how we can be more aggressive
I'm happy to take a meeting anytime
but in the time I've been
Commerce Secretary
I've put over 200 Chinese entities
on the entity list
More than a quarter of the Chinese entities
on the list were put there by us
Last October, we did
something this country's never done before
in the breadth and depth
of the semiconductor controls that we made
as applied to the entire country
of China
We've amped up enforcement
and every day we are on it
to try to be
as aggressive as possible
to make sure that China doesn't get our technologies
to advance their military
I would just say that
Having said that
look, it's a constant battle
like it is a daily battle
Right now, the trade rep
Ambassador Tai
is conducting the review
of the 301
which was focused on IP
and so the point you make
is an excellent one
We should have zero tolerance for China ripping off
American IP and hurting American businesses
so we are constantly looking
at ways that we can protect American businesses
and make sure they play by the rules
Let me be clear, we can outcompete China
if they play by the rules
and so ensuring a level playing field
is a top priority of ours
and you'll be happy to have a further discussion
I think reciprocal trade is the key amount of time
but I'll take you up on that offer, we'd love to sit down
We have a lot of good ideas, we just need to be more aggressive
Thank you
Mrs. Meng
Thank you Mr. Chairman
and thank you Madam Secretary for being here
and for your great work
and for literally travelling around the country
continuing to find ways
to invest in the American people
I also wanted to ask about
the potential
proposed cuts
of either fiscal year
return to fiscal year 2022 levels
or a 22%
reduction, both of whom
we've heard from the majority
If there were these proposed cuts
I wanted to ask you
about the potential
impact in two
specific areas
one is on our national security
there's been a lot of
talk today and of course
concern about national security
including
making sure that we are keeping sensitive
goods and technology out
of the hands of our adversaries
and if we are serious
about being aggressive
and serious about being proactive
and keeping and making sure
that America is first
like I tell my teenage son
it's not always about just
criticising the adversary
or an opponent's weaknesses
but seeing how we can put
ourselves on a higher ground
making us
more competitive
to put us first
so number one, I wanted to know
how potential cuts would impact
advances in national security
and two, I wanted to
ask about potential cuts and their impact
on American jobs and
economic competitiveness
would cuts
weaken our nation's
economic competitiveness
would it affect America's
ability to maintain
and increase the number
of American jobs throughout this
country?
So first let me say I have a 16 year old son
so if you have any guidance on that
I'd be happy to get it
I think yes
is what I
feel
we have been consistently
making investments in
our supply chain, in research and
development, in manufacturing
and we're starting to see the benefit of that
manufacturing jobs are coming back
supply chain is coming back to America
you know
coal communities and forgotten communities
manufacturing communities
like the one I'm from
are being revitalized
the investments in
BIS
you know the congressman's
you make an excellent point
which is to say we have to be
vigilant on this
if we don't have the enforcement agents
we won't be able to do
our job effectively
if we don't have enough analysts we won't be able to do
with respect to
BIS so I think that
look at what we did with Russia
very quickly
we got a coalition of over 39
countries together
since then we've put more than 500
Russian entities on the entity list
we've stopped hundreds of millions of dollars
of technology
going into Russia
we wouldn't have been able
to do any of that if we didn't have
the funding so
I don't know
yes I think it would have an impact
and our ability to compete, our ability to invest
and our
job creation
Thank you and I wanted to
also quickly ask about
potential cuts with the census
I know that we are far away from the next
census but as you know
fiscal year 2024 is the last
year in the Census
Bureau's exploration of design
innovations leading up to the selection
of an operational design for the next
census. The budget request
for the Bureau is 1.6 billion
with 409 million for the
census preparation
last year I had expressed my
concern to you about under
counting America's children
and I am still concerned that
potential budget cuts would impact
the research that you are doing that would allow
the most effective, innovative and secure
methods of data collection
from being pursued
Madam Secretary, can you
discuss what the impact on the preparation
for the census would be if there
were cuts?
So although 2030 seems like a long
time away, the census
Bureau right now has more than 50
research projects ongoing
to improve the way we collect
the data
I should say that everything
about the census should be apolitical
database, fact based and
we rely on the experts
so they have 50
research projects going on now
this is a very important year
we have called
for investments in
IT, research, design
to make sure that we get the most
accurate information about how many
Americans there are, how many
people we have living in America and how
they live their lives
so yes,
I think it's fair to say
that we would be less accurate
in 2030 if we weren't able to make
the investments necessary to
do that collection properly
Thank you, I yield back
Mr. Clyde
Thank you Mr. Chairman
Secretary
Raimondo, thank you for being here today
and to discuss
the Department of Commerce's fiscal year
2024 budget request
from your request summary
I see that the Department is asking for
$12.3 billion this fiscal year
an 11% increase
over FY23 enacted
that's a fair bit of money
Do you believe
the Department of Commerce
should receive or spend unauthorized
funds?
I mean
I would leave it to Congress
to decide what
to authorize and appropriate
what I can tell you is
we are using
and spending and investing the appropriated
money in accordance with Congress's
intent
What is your department's current spending authorization?
I'll have to get you the
number, I'll get back to you
So you don't know
Not off the top of my head, no
So you came today to request $12.3
billion from the American taxpayers
yet you don't know if and how much
you're legally authorized to have
I'm sure my team
could tell me in a second
Okay
Well, according to the Congressional Budget Office
and this committee's
fiscal year 2023 report
many of the department's bureaus and programs
are currently not authorized
some for more than decades
Let me give you an example
The National Oceanographic and Atmospheric Administration
has not been completely authorized
since 1992
The National Weather Service since 1993
The National Telecommunications and Information Administration
The Bureau of Industry and Security
The Economic Development Administration 2008
and the National Institute of Standards
and Technology
since 2013
So you've been the secretary for two years
Were you aware of these
expired authorizations prior to
submitting the 2024 budget request?
As I said
We
This is in
I respect Congress's authority
It's up to Congress to decide what's authorized
what to appropriate and how to make those decisions
My job
and I am faithfully undertaking that
is to
administer appropriated monies
consistent with the law
with transparency
and accountability to
taxpayers
In Congress we have authorizing committees
and we have appropriating
We have one appropriating committee, this one
and we have 18 or 19 authorizing committees
and every department
of the federal government has an authorizing
committee that authorizes its
use or that authorizes
whether it exists
legally authorizes it
Okay
and I'm
puzzled as to why the Department of
Commerce has not requested authorization
from the authorizing committees
As I said
we could take that up with the
authorizing committees
That would be great, that would be the energy and commerce
committee and potentially the science
space and technology committee I guess
Your department is broken
down through both authorizing
That's what happens when you cover
everything from fish to space
I get it
So
So do you think
it's not your responsibility
to go get an authorization from Congress?
It's never my responsibility
to tell Congress what to do
My responsibility is to
carry out my job
in the confines of Congress's intent
which is what we're doing
Okay, well
I know that I'm new to the appropriations
committee but
I've been learning the processes of it
and I just want to ensure
that there's proper oversight
and accountability are afforded to
the federal responsibilities into tax
dollar expenditures
I know past appropriators may not
have strictly adhered to this process
but this majority came
in on a commitment to regular order
and regular order means
that you have an authorization
and then you appropriate
to that authorization
If you do not have an authorization how can you
appropriate to something that doesn't exist?
Once again that to me is in
Congress's jurisdiction and
so I'll leave it to you and your colleagues to
sort through
those issues. Well I hope
that you will take this then and go to the
appropriate authorizing committees
and request the appropriate
authorizations because it's
going to be difficult to support
an appropriation without an authorization
Thank you
Thank you and I yield back. Mr.
Ruffersberger
Okay secretary first thing
thank you for being here from
where I sit I think
you've done a good job you have a lot of
different issues you have to deal with
We've been very supportive
of building our semiconductor
computer chips
and I'm concerned
that we have not
we don't have the workforce
to go where we need to
go. In an
article you said that we simply will
not be successful in achieving
the national security goals of
the chips initiatives unless we
invest in our workforce period
and full stop
you said for decades we've taken
our eye off the ball with manufacturing
which means that worker
supply of people with
the skills to do super technical manufacturing
has withered and so
we need to be honest about it
but also embrace it as an opportunity
to come up with creative
solutions. To that
end the commerce department is asking every
company buying for a share of
39 billion in direct funding
for semiconductor manufacturing to
develop and outline plans for how
they plan to build a skilled and diverse
workforce including by working
with high schools and community
colleges. Can you tell us
more on where we need to build the workforce
both on the government side and the commercial side?
Yes, thank you.
Real quickly too because I
have a space question.
Okay, well
I'll say it.
Right before coming here I was
at a semiconductor event with Senator
Young talking about this topic. It was
hosted by Purdue. The industry
estimates that there's
a hundred thousand
semiconductor there'll be a hundred thousand semiconductor
technicians short
in the next few years and those are
non-college degree jobs
if we don't train more.
They also estimate that they're very short
of PhD engineers and
chemists.
So my point
in making those comments is that
it's not enough to build
the buildings. You need to have people who have
the skills to do the job and
right now given our very low unemployment
rate that is a challenge. So we have
to think creatively. By the way it's also
true for building facilities.
The unemployment rate in the building
trades is
in some states zero.
Full employment. Every one of these
facilities will take between five and ten thousand building
trades to build for years.
So my point is that we have
to get and those are non-college degree jobs
working with high schools and apprenticeship
programs, figuring out ways to tap
communities
that haven't previously been in the business
of the building trade. So long story short
I have a sense
of urgency about training people
because it's necessary to meet the mission.
Okay. I'm going
to switch to space real quick.
I'd like to ask you about the growing problem
of orbital debris
and how it relates to the efforts
of the office of space commerce.
The Russians last year tested
an anti-seattle
satellite missile.
They created a debris field that was so
big it threatened the safety
operations of our international space station.
These are thousands of active
satellites. There are
tens of thousands of space debris ranging
from nuts and bolts to old rocket
stages and all of them can cause
damage. The office of space commerce
is charged with protecting the space
services
that are critical to our nation's infrastructure
sustaining US
space sector leadership
globally and international space
cooperation.
What are your quick thoughts
on the growing problem of orbital debris
as well as the growing
congestion due to a large
consolation?
Please talk about China as well.
Yeah. So my quick thoughts
are that it is a problem
and it is a growing problem. I mean the good
news is that there's more
commercial opportunities in space.
We're innovating more and so there are more
satellites. The
problem is, as you say, it's
congested. There's much more opportunity
for collisions, much more opportunity
for
mal intent,
stealing information and
such. So what we are doing,
a few things quickly. One
is we're asking for increased funding, which we
got last year. We're asking for more this year
to have our space tracking
system. I
think of it as air traffic control for
space, which is to say we need to
know what's going on, what's available
to cut down on the collisions. And so
we're investing in that. We've
increased the staff
by 75 percent at space
commerce. We've put a
new director in, Rich Dalbello,
who's excellent. We've elevated space
commerce from lower in
NOAA to higher up and giving
it more attention. I'd be happy
to have Deputy Secretary Graves come and sit
with you because he's focused on this.
The bottom line is it's a problem.
It's going to get worse as you see
more commercial space
activities. China and
Russia are both a problem
and so we need a much better system
which we're building, which we think will be operational
by the end of fiscal year 24
to have a better sense
of what's happening in orbit.
Thank you. I yield back.
Mr. Adderholt.
Thank you, Madam Secretary.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
I just wanted to ask
about the steel and aluminum
232 tariff.
I understand we face
October 2023 deadline
to conclude negotiations
on the global arrangement
on sustainable steel
and aluminum. And
I also understand that both
sides have now exchanged initial
concept papers.
But it appears that there is fundamental
differences between the proposed
proposal that's been put forward
by the Biden administration
and also the response from the
European Commission.
Given the differences
that are
apparent at this point,
what is your assessment of
the prospects for concluding an agreement
before the date
of October 23,
to possibly
get some kind of
negotiation finalized?
Yeah. A couple of things.
Ambassador Tai and the
USTR are the
lead in this negotiation.
But I am
aware of it. In fact,
I was just meeting with the trade
minister from the EU. We'll be
headed over to Sweden
in June
to continue to make progress
on this. I would say
that we're hopeful to hit the
deadline and we're making progress.
We still have many months to go.
But as a long-term solution, I think
it's the right solution.
So Ambassador
Tai is closer to it than
I am, but it's a priority.
And the Europeans
are working with us constructively
to try to have it
resolved.
What are
your options if, for some
reason, it's not
an agreement that's not reached by that
date?
You know, I think we need to operate
as though we will. And so I'm
going to
the administration's going to work.
There's always an
option to continue going after October.
But I think
everyone is focused on having that
happen.
It sets the right incentive
structure
to have more green
steel and aluminum.
And, you know,
the problem with steel and aluminum is
China has been flooding the market
with excess capacity
and cheap, dirty
steel and aluminum. And so this is the best
tool, we think, to
prevent that. So I think our
goal is to have it done.
Do you anticipate that
the Section 232 tariff could be
reimposed on imports
from EU member countries?
That we don't, you know,
I'm not going to go there because I'm going to
choose to focus on
hitting the deadline and getting it done.
It was
I was in the middle of the
negotiation to
adjust the
tariffs and I don't think we want to go back
to that.
Let me switch over to
situation with
weather situation. So far in
2023, we've seen a real
alarming amount of deadly
destructive tornadoes rip through
the south and especially
my home state of Alabama.
My rural constituents are
especially vulnerable to tornadoes
because we have a radar gap
in west Alabama.
The severe storms that produce
deadly tornadoes are typically
low altitude systems that
evade the legacy
radar system
and that creates the gap in the coverage.
My colleague from Alabama,
Congresswoman Terry Sewell,
who is my neighbor
to the south, we have, we
had a very productive conversation
earlier this month with the National
Weather Service Director King Graham
about this very
issue and
we discussed some of the issues
that we're facing. He committed
to us in that conversation to work with
us to find a solution for west Alabama
until the next generation
radars are installed
throughout the country. And of course
obviously the next generation radars
will be a while before that will take
place, but until that takes
place, you know,
there is a gap and
the constituents, our
constituents in Alabama
are in that gap
and I guess my
question to you, would you commit to working
with the director,
Dr. Graham, to find
and rapidly implement
a solution to resolve this
radar gap that potentially
could cause many more deaths in the state
of Alabama? Absolutely. I did
not know. I was unaware of that gap
and I do
know how devastating the tornadoes have
been. In fact, I recently was
on the phone with an employee of the Commerce
Department in that part
of the world whose house was destroyed by the
tornadoes. So I took
note, I will look in on it. The gap,
the situation with the gap is
it's like EF3
and EF4 can be
detected, but EF1 and EF2 cannot
be detected. But as you know, EF1
and EF2 tornadoes,
EF1 and EF2 can be very deadly as
well. I see. So that's
where the gap is.
Okay, yes, we'll work with you.
Congresswoman Sewell and I have been together trying to
work on this, so we appreciate your commitment
to that. Thank you. Yes.
Mr. Morrell.
Thank you, Chairman Rogers and
ranking member Kyright for
holding this important hearing and thank you,
Madam Secretary, for
not only your service but your leadership
of the department
and the important work you have and certainly
for joining us here today.
Last year, I was one of the
voices calling for significant investment
in the regional innovation and the CHIPS and Science
Act, which is something I know that
you've been very, very supportive of
and worked hard on. And the final
bill, as you obviously know,
created the regional technology and
innovation hubs that designate and fund
up to 20 tech hubs of innovation
under-invested
in communities and regions
poised to make a leap forward in the innovation economy.
Excuse me.
Upstate New York, and I've shared
this with you before, is an
excellent example of
a region poised to make such a
leap forward. My district,
which is Rochester, New York, alone is home
to two top-tier research
universities. It was also identified
by MIT
economist Simon Johnson
and Jonathan Gruber and Jumpstart in America
as the top technology hub candidate
in the United States. So I'm
certain if the Commerce Department
and Congress continue to prioritize tech
hubs, we can unleash the potential of regions
across the United States and
accelerate the development of dozens of leading-age
technologies,
particularly in underserved regions. I think you
mentioned the big hubs that tend to attract
a lot of the venture capital money. So
what role would you say
that the Department
expect the
tech hubs to play in collaboration
with other pieces in the Chips
and Science Act investments? And will
the Department continue to prioritize
the tech hubs among your other
CHIPS responsibilities?
Yes, thank you. So
it is a priority, and we
will continue to prioritize
it. It all
relates to national security
insofar as we need to tap into
the technology, know-how,
and research and development that we have in
this country everywhere that
it exists. I mean, in
your world,
Rochester Institute of Technology,
other universities,
upstate New York is filled
with great
universities,
advanced technology,
and, you know, as I said
before, these great technologies
don't exist just at MIT,
Harvard, and Stanford. So
we have to,
the way we plan to roll this out,
and we'll be rolling it out shortly,
coming months, is it'll be
a competitive process. We're going to
ask each community to put forward
a full,
robust application, getting
the whole community, you know, public
sector, private sector, universities,
and we
think, you know, we'll designate 20 or
more tech hubs,
we'll fund, I don't
know, plus or minus a dozen,
10, 11, but
I hope that's just the beginning, because I know
there are places
that we should invest in all over this country
to tap into the full potential.
Yeah, and you know
this better than most, having
come out of the world, I think something
90% of the venture capital dollars are in about
five regional communities,
so that certainly excludes many communities.
I know that the
Science and
Tech, or the Chips and Science
Act put the tech hubs at authorization
of 10 billion
in the bill. Only 500
million was authorized for appropriation
last
year, and I wonder if you could just address
if they're not funded
to a much more appropriate level,
the missed opportunity there.
It's a huge missed opportunity. I mean, with
500 million,
I mean, you can do the math
yourself. I mean, if we were to pick
10, that's only 50
million each, it's actually less than that,
because we'll need to put some money out for
planning grants and such.
There's surely more than five
or ten places around America
that are
have cutting-edge research. As I said,
I just came from an event hosted by
Indiana. Amazing
what they have going on in the heartland
with Purdue and their institutions,
and I could say that it could go around the table
here. So, we
need more than
six, seven, eight, nine, ten
places, and frankly, they need
more money to really build this out. If you look
at places like, say, Pittsburgh,
they are now
leading edge in robotics,
but it's taken time
and a good deal of money
and public-private partnerships. That's
the final thing I'll say. This can't be done
with government alone or government money.
Our money has to be a small piece of the pie
that catalyzes other money,
private sector, coming
together, and that's how we're going to judge
who gets the money, the strength
of the coalition that's coming together.
Well, thank you again for your leadership.
I look forward to continue to work with you,
and thanks so much, and I yield back, Mr. Chair.
Mr. Elsie?
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you, Madam Secretary.
Do you prefer Madam Secretary or
Governor? Governor. You do?
Okay. I don't blame you. All right,
Governor. Well,
appreciate you asking that. Thank you for being
here. I know that as a
father of young children that doing this job
and being a parent and father
is difficult, and so I appreciate the
time that you've dedicated in service to your nation
and to your state. Same to you.
I appreciate you saying that. Thank you very much. We have Rugby in
Common. I don't know, I don't think you were front
line, but I'm sure you were an outstanding
back. I was a scrum half. Okay.
I'm sure you're very good at it. Not
really, but. Listen, I just
wanted to talk about something that's really important
to the voters of District 6 in Texas,
just south of Dallas,
a largely rural community,
and let's talk about the census real
quick. The Department of Commerce handles many different
sub-agencies, including the Census Bureau.
The Census Bureau was established in 1902
to count the entire
US population every 10 years as mandated
in the Constitution for the
apportionment of seats in the US House of Representatives
along with other services.
It was reported that
the census undercounted several states' populations
in 2020 after a
post enumeration survey. I can get you that
reference if you need it
down the road. This included Arkansas,
Florida, Illinois, Mississippi, Tennessee,
and my home state of Texas.
The Census Bureau also
overcounted eight states, including Delaware,
Hawaii, Massachusetts, Minnesota,
New York, Ohio, Rhode Island,
and Utah.
As we talk about—and it's
very important to my voters. They bring it up
all the time. If the people of Texas are under
representative in the House,
in the number of apportionment and congressmen,
and the people of another state are
overrepresented, then the Census
Bureau has threatened the very foundation of our
republic in a way that ensures
the people of Texas are not fully represented.
The very foundation of our
system requires an accurate count of the number of American
citizens who are eligible to vote
and are represented by their representatives
in the House. So the
impression for the folks in my district are that
the last census count was used by
somebody, say, on the
left to ensure that democrat-leaning states were
overcounted and conservative-leaning states
were undercounted. Five
of the six states that were undercounted were majority
republican. Seven of the eight states that were
overcounted were majority democrat.
That doesn't really—
I'm not a statistician, but that
doesn't sound very good to me. So
let's talk about the budget. The Census Bureau
is requesting $1.6 billion in
fiscal year 2024, which includes an additional
$164 million for the 2030
census. How do y'all
plan on fixing the
lessons learned from the 2020 census? Because
representation
in congress ultimately determines the electoral
college,
and it's winner-take-all. So the folks in my
district would really like to—they don't really trust the
census. So I'd like to hear how you're going to
fix that.
It's an excellent question, and I appreciate the
question. Let me say a few
things. So first of all, you're right,
which is to say there's
no place for politics
or political views
in how the census is
administered.
It should be
do the count, right? Do the count.
Who's living in Texas, who's living in
wherever, accurately,
et cetera.
So I give you that commitment. I, of course,
wasn't here for the last census,
but
there'll be zero political
interference. We're getting ready now for 2030.
The instruction to the team
is do your work, be apolitical, count
the data, and make sure everyone's counted.
I will say
2020 was really hard. I was
the governor at the time. It was in the middle
of a lot of challenges
to collect in 2020.
So we're learning
from that
experience and figuring out how
we can make it better. And as I said before
with Congressman Meng, right now
we have like 50 research
projects going on in the census
to figure out how to be more
accurate. So I guess
I would just say I agree fully with
the sentiment and be happy
to follow up with you, you know, more
specifically. Rob Santos,
who runs the census, is his top flight
statistician from Texas
and can have
him follow up. I'd sure appreciate that because
I think finding out, you know, when you're
a fighter pilot, as my
friend Mike Garcia and I flew together,
you brief, you
do the mission, and then you debrief. And I think
a serious debrief that
would tell us exactly what lessons
learned we have and then going forward
so that this doesn't happen again because
I don't care. 2016, the left
thought that the election was stolen. 2020,
there's a lot of folks on my side that
aren't, don't have any faith
in the integrity of the election. So
it is important. It's
absolutely essential for
the survival of our republic the way we want
it to, that we do this right next
time. So thank you very much for your time.
I yield back, Mr. Chairman.
Thank you,
Mr. Chairman. I appreciate that.
Governor, it's great to see you and
you've done a wonderful job. We really
appreciate your long, long public
service. So thank you very
much. The National
Institute of Standards and Technology,
NIST. It's headquartered
in my district
and it's one of the leading agencies.
We were there together
driving scientific innovation
and some of our
most pressing problems.
However, the facilities
are a train wreck.
The buildings were built in the 1950s.
The scientists,
while they're great on science,
they aren't good on asking for money.
They aren't good on explaining why their buildings
are falling down
and that it impedes their scientific
work
and costs us untold
tens of millions of dollars
by working in poor facilities.
So
China, of course, has taken the opposite
task. They've invested
in their equivalence of NIST.
They actually have five facilities
that were a dead ringer,
a copy of NIST,
that they did when they came over here and looked at our
NIST. They went out and built five of their own.
So they're looking to overtake us
in this area
in standards and, you know, meteorology.
So
last year, with Chairman Cartwright's support,
we were able to increase the construction
funding in NIST
to 130 million.
This year, the President's budget came back at
262 million.
And
we're 2.3 billion, backlog,
don't forget, 2.3 billion
behind. So I just want to
stress the fact it's so important
that with all the noise that cut the budget
to 22 levels,
you know, we can't shoot our
nose off despite ourselves
and we need to invest for the long
term. As a business guy,
that's the right way to do it.
So could you just talk for a second
about that hidden cost
of these deteriorating facilities,
especially the cost of talent?
I mean, the director told me she
loses top talent to China.
Go to China to work.
They don't want to work somewhere nice.
Yeah.
Well, thank you, Congressman, and thank you for your consistent
support. I would invite anyone here
to come with
me for a visit to NIST
facilities. The Congressman and I have gone.
And it is true that
these facilities
need investment.
I will tell you, the people working
in NIST are top
notch. We have Nobel Prize
winning physicists who work for
NIST.
We have this leading
artificial intelligence, quantum
and cyber
experts work at NIST.
But as you say, they work in
dilapidated buildings,
which is unfair,
sometimes unsafe, and
prevents them.
The National Academy's assessment
of the condition of NIST R&D
facilities
finds them to be quote unquote
unacceptable. Their report
found that a median
of 20 percent of
all researcher time each
year is lost due to
facility impacts of their
work. So
they're less productive. You know, they're
less productive. I think it's probably at least 20 percent,
having been there myself.
Where they go,
they go to the private sector, they go
to universities, but we just
have to make these investments, which is why we're asking
for more investing.
We certainly have phenomenal talent
there. It just absolutely blows your mind
how smart these guys and gals
are, women are, men and women, but
the young researchers,
they have choices.
They can go private or they can
go abroad. And that's what we seem
to lose in that pipeline, as our
researchers just age out.
We don't have the young folks with the new ideas
coming up, because
work facilities and
standards matter
to them more.
Agree, to track new
people. And again,
back to everything we've been talking about,
leading the world in technology,
what they focus on is artificial intelligence,
cyber security, quantum computing,
everything America needs to lead
in, and
they are doing that, but the facilities
in which they're doing that are holding
them back and making them
less productive. Fantastic, I appreciate
your support and I look forward
to the next round to talk about some broadband
stuff, so I yield back to
Chairman.
I would like to do a second
round of questions, but
the Secretary
has an obligation at
four o'clock. So we can go quick.
We want to accommodate her
schedule.
So we'll do a second round
but very brief.
Hopefully three minutes or
less.
And I'll recognize myself.
The assistance
to coal communities
program administered by
ADA
has been critical in providing
funding and tactical
assistance to communities
affected by the decline of the coal
industry.
I represent one of the biggest coal
mining, former coal mining
communities in the country.
And I understand the importance of this
program for our communities
and I encourage you to prioritize
grant funding for that
program especially.
Can you give us an update on the program's
progress in supporting
economic development
and diversification efforts in coal
communities across the country?
Yes. This is a top priority
of mine, of President Biden's, and
I know it matters a lot to you in
Kentucky.
The update is that
we are investing at record
amounts and will continue to
do so and we are creating jobs
in these communities in new industries
which is really very exciting.
So for example, in Kentucky we've
put more than $23
million through ADA
into coal communities
since I've been secretary, effectively
to create new jobs, to do job
training, same in West Virginia.
With the ARP money
we were able to take
$300 million and put it
into coal communities. And I would
simply say, as I said before,
these communities won't be brought back
to life unless we invest.
And you know
what happens otherwise, no jobs,
opioid addiction,
we have
to be there for them to get new jobs,
new job training, new industries,
and so we're extremely focused
on it. We're trying to
reinvent the economy
of my region
with especially high-tech
stuff. In fact,
I've coined a phrase that
fits our goal
and it's called
Silicon Hauler.
So thank you for
working with us.
Do you agree with FBI
Director Ray's national
security concerns about TikTok?
And do you agree with ODNI
Director Haynes
assessment that
China is collecting foreign data
to target
audiences for information
campaigns?
I do. I do. You know, I don't think
we can limit. I
think that all of these
connected apps and many
other technology
apps pose
risks. And
in fact, I look forward to
working with Congress in a bipartisan way
to enhance our security in that respect.
Mr. Cartwright?
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Madam Secretary,
last year's hearing, we talked about Ukraine
and how
the Bureau of Industry and Security
is a critical agency in aiding
our efforts to enforce the export
controls on
Russia and Belarus in
response to Russia's war
against Ukraine. We provided $22
million in supplemental funding
to assist BIS
on that front last year. Can you give us
an update on how these funds
have been used and is it working?
Thank you. Thank you for the support.
I would say, yes, it is working.
We have 39
we led a coalition of 39
countries around the world.
We've put more than 500 Russian entities
on the entity list.
We've stopped hundreds of shipments
going into
Russia. We know
they're
struggling to continue
the war because they can't repair
equipment.
They don't have the semiconductors to repair the equipment.
They don't have the spare parts to conduct the equipment.
But it is, as I said before
with Rep Garcia, it's a
daily vigilance.
It makes my blood boil every time I learn
about
a downed piece of equipment
that has American equipment still
in it. So we're constantly on it.
Is it working? Yes.
Do we need to stay on it every day? Yes.
Can we do that work without
resources? No.
Well, you have been diligent
in coming to our classified
security briefings.
And I encourage you to keep doing that. Keep us
posted. Heel back, Mr. Chairman.
Thank you, Mr. Chair.
I'll be brief, Governor.
VX, you remember VX, a very
lethal chemical weapon
gas, about a thousand times more potent
than sarin.
If we had indications that
VX gas or powder
was in route
and we had indications from the Intelligence Committee
or Community DoD
Maritime Surveillance,
that there was a plan to
ship that VX
through Mexico across our
southern border into the United States to be
used as a chemical weapon,
what would the response of the Department of
Commerce be?
I mean,
I don't know
the details of that, so I'm quite
resident to talk about
a specific issue, but
look, anything like that would be
an interagency response
led by the intelligence
community and Department of Homeland Security.
But we would do whatever we needed to
do to support the effort.
Making sure we're tracking the
vessels, the points of
origin of the material coming from China
through to Mexico
and assist the DoD,
Homeland Security and the interdiction of
what would be effectively a weapon of
mass destruction. We would do whatever was called
upon us to meet the mission.
I think we have that scenario today. It's just not called
VX, it's called Fentanyl. We have
active precursor exports
coming out of China with this known
game plan of sending them to Mexico,
taking that powder, making
the pill in Mexico and then shipping
to the United States where, ironically
and painfully, we've actually lost more people
from Fentanyl than VX gas in the
history of the planet just in the last
couple of days. So I
think this is the paradigm that commerce,
DoD,
Homeland and the intelligence
communities need to take.
I don't know how to spread that
in this administration and get everyone
to absorb that paradigm, but
that's not happening right now.
We have a weapon of mass destruction coming across
our southern borders, killing 100,000 Americans
every year, 30 times more
than people died on 9-11.
And this executive branch,
to include commerce, DoD
and state,
are doing nothing to mitigate that
except for
enforcement once it gets across our borders.
Look, I would say a couple
of quick things. I'm mindful of time.
This I did see upfront and
very painfully and personally as governor.
And Fentanyl
sometimes even touching it can be deadly.
That's right. Just like VX.
It is horrific.
Much
begins in China
and is synthetic.
The thing I would say to you is that this is
a priority of the presidents.
I was with the president in
Mexico. We talked extensively
with President López Obrador.
I met just a week
ago with Secretary Blinken on this.
I'm going to be doing a lot more private sector
in the US outreach.
So I disagree that we're doing nothing,
but I will tell you it's a priority.
What we are doing is ineffective.
This has to be treated like a chemical weapon
of mass destruction coming across the Pacific Ocean
and through our borders.
I'm out of time. I yield back.
Ms. Ming.
Thank you. Before I ask my quick question,
I do want to give credit where credit is due
in relation to my
colleagues' question about
the census being from the state of New York.
I want to applaud my leaders
at the city and the state levels,
one, for investing
money and time in making
sure that we were counting
accurately in the state of New
York, having
a get out the count campaign,
and two, not engaging
in fear mongering and
trying to determine who deserves
to be counted or not.
Madam Secretary, my question
is about the
department's regulation of 3D printed
firearms.
When the Trump administration moved
jurisdiction of export oversight from
state to commerce, they created
an enforcement loophole which has allowed
for the dissemination of instructions
for printing 3D guns.
Last October, I led a letter
with Senator Markey
asking President Biden to strengthen the
regulatory oversight of these guns
specifically by having your department
strike the ready for insertion
qualification and clarifying
that the rule included instruction files
that were emailed or otherwise
made available to foreign persons.
Mr. Chairman, I request
unanimous consent to insert my letter
in the record.
Thank you.
Madam Secretary, do you believe the current
version of the regulations are broad
enough to apply to any known
versions of currently viable
3D firearm files?
And can we get a commitment
from you to issue guidance to that
aspect?
I would say that you have been consistent
in your focus on this
and I admire that.
You can get a commitment that
I will send Under Secretary
Estevez to sit with you and talk
through it.
I will just say that we still work
with the Department of State.
This is all an interagency process
and state is at the table.
And we absolutely share
your passion
in making sure that none of this
controlled substances,
software, et cetera,
can get into the wrong hands.
So we'll follow up.
Thank you. I yield back. What time to spare?
Mr. Claude.
I'd like to follow up
on
Rep
Elsie's questions regarding the census.
Who gets counted?
Who gets counted? Everyone who lives
in the country gets counted.
Who lives in the country? Okay.
So does that include illegals and permanent
residents?
If you live here, yes.
There's no citizenship requirement,
nor should there be.
In the last two years, over six million
illegals have entered our country.
Illegals cannot vote.
Only citizens can vote. Am I correct?
Yes.
Therefore, the more illegals that
enter the country,
that then
disproportionately
disenfranchises
those of us who are citizens who can vote
because we don't have
proper representation.
Is that not right?
I would dispute that characterization,
but
my job is to run the census
faithfully in accordance with the law and the Constitution
to count everyone who lives
here, and that is what we are doing
faithfully.
Okay. All right.
Well, I guess we'll just have to disagree on that
where it comes to
citizens versus illegals
because I think that
that disproportionately
for any particular area,
it disproportionately
disenfranchises the American
citizen because then
it takes fewer citizens
to create one particular
representative
and more illegals then can do that.
I mean, if you look at the six million
illegals, that's the equivalent
of
what, 12?
12 congressional seats? No, not 12.
Nine congressional seats.
That's a lot of people. Thank you, and I yield back.
Mr.
Tron, can you keep it to one minute?
I could do it, Mr. Chairman.
Thank you, Governor. Great time.
Quickly,
in all the census counting problem,
that was Trump working really hard
to disenfranchise and not count
the minorities, just so we're all clear
about the honest truth of that.
Broadband, going to be a game changer.
Rural America, going to be a whole
other world. It's so
awesome it's going to happen. 42.5
billion coming out of your group.
April Delaney's pushing it
out. We're working with her. She's great.
Are we on track for
June on the funding?
June 30th. Every state will know
by June 30th what their
amount is.
Great. In workforce development
programs, we're going to need a ton of
workforce. Same problem you have in the
CHIPS area. Putting this
broadband in, we don't have
the people to put it in.
Thoughts on that? What do we need?
Listen, this is a huge issue.
Again,
the unemployment rate among
plumbers, pipefitters, welders in
your states, you can't find anyone.
Broadband alone, we think,
will require about 100,000
people. Technicians,
fibresplicers, people to lay the fiber and the whole
thing. CHIPS, another 100,000.
So we need to
train, and the great thing is
high paying jobs that don't require a
college degree.
We are baking in
workforce development into
everything we do at Commerce.
In fact, part of our request in EDA
is $100 million for good jobs.
CHIPS money, broadband money,
train people, and
get them jobs.
Only we're ever going to get it right. Thank you, I yield back.
Well, Madam Secretary,
it's two minutes after four.
You've been saved by the bell.
Well, I don't know.
Representative Troun says this was a good time.
That concludes today's hearing.
Thank you very much, Madam Secretary.
Thank you for your time.
It's my pleasure, thank you.
With that objection, all members
will have seven legislative days
to submit additional written questions
for the witness or additional
materials for the record.
The hearing is adjourned.
Diolch yn fawr.